not hungry
assalamu alaikom peace bill you ready
from the dean so maybe it's nice little
time for the show today i'm d'lai you're
tuning in and we're gonna be talking
about happy that's right are you happy
how can you be happy what makes you
happy and this is what we're gonna be
discussing and this week's show and much
more so make sure that you're tuning in
we got so much to talk about you know
about the video that went viral you
probably watched it maybe you didn't but
we're gonna be discussing a little bit
about that too so don't go anywhere all
this is more of my next guest here on
the Dean show
this is the welcome back to the D show
Salaam alaikum peace be with you
how are you I'm Dylan thank you for
being with us on today's show my
pleasure to be here at you when it made
a sign how you got to come in for this
exciting sign that was made my head
actually fits through it what do you
think you look beautiful happy that's
right
hamdulillah so happiness that's what
we're Tama everybody is looking for
happiness everybody every male female
young old Muslim or non-muslim they all
want to seek happiness yeah so we wanted
to start off there was a video and some
people have made this video and we
wanted to get some feedback to see
really what our Islamic stance was it
what you know we had to say about it and
from there we can take off absolutely
so first of all I'm very thankful to
lost heart Allah he allowed me to be in
your presence and allow me to be allowed
to be seen by the brothers and sisters I
ask Allah subhana WA Ta'ala this of
benefit and to make this as means of
happiness to everybody that watches us
amen I mean Anatomy with this being said
first of all we ask Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala award everyone behind that video
we ask Allah to grant them the highest
levels in Jannah and to see him a Hamas
of Allah and he was rewarded for their
intentions first of all we need to know
our limits that's very important to know
your limits even me as a speaker right
now I need to know my limits to what
extent we can say it's Haram hello am i
exactly meaning can I say hi Haram can I
sign on a large behalf every time you
mention a fatwa
Haram are you actually standing on a lot
of behalf so before the actual content
of that video automated something very
very important actually even more
important the content itself which is
the brotherhood and sisterhood
when you find both parties the party
that approves of it and the party that's
against it how they're commenting
against each other accusing one others
intention or you're an extremist or
you're a hypocrite behind the screen or
this in frontier like that and others
all years are doing these videos to
promo
Muslims are for example they're liberals
etc I will open my and grow guys and
girls can dance and we won't have spread
corruption accusing intentions that's
number one another thing there's very
bad is that people getting fed to us on
both sides and I'm talking down real
real stuff right here when someone says
okay you know what
dancing is haram period do you know what
academically speaking how serious that
statement that you're mentioning
anything brother Eddie any any ritual is
Haram unless proven otherwise
and every natural act is halal unless
proven otherwise so everybody that says
something is how I'm doing to bring what
what's the word evidence may Allah bless
you without evidence your conversation
your your whatever you say is pretty
weak so yes dancing can get some people
to Jenna maybe perhaps if I wait Dan
cetera husband so wife we're talking
about now a wife dancing to her husband
to her husband Nam but now you want to
go to dancing in the public why not go
ask the scholars before doing such act
that my deal create a lot of controversy
just think about it somehow does think
about it I'm not saying how I trying to
think if it slam tells the sisters not
to wear an ankle bracelet okay don't
worry ankle bracelet
what about shaking her whole body in
front of a meal right just thinking I'm
not accusing anyone's intention I'm just
saying some practical steps right why
not an ankle bracelet well now go ahead
and lab rate on the ankle bracelet this
is it so the ankle bracelet some
scholars say because it grabs attention
maybe whenever at the time in the past
when the woman does this and the the
bracelet shaken each she needs attention
etc so whatever the wisdom behind it
just just something to for her
protection
yes affirm protection don't do that for
example the perfume right so Russell
mice of a lodge it was said look and
everyday is watching us makes you say
Solano send them right me allows peace
and blessings be upon the Prophet
Mohammed so the Prophet says whoever a
woman that walks by a man and she puts a
lot of perfume and the man smelt that
perfume and desired that lady then as if
she committed zina
music Allah's refuge from that is that
clear so such a high level of perfume in
man if she's dancing and and as a man
generally get enticed by these things
we're not saying as simple as like doing
this and so on but Jenny dancing overall
so my advice is that go and consult with
the scholars
just to avoid being hit with this stuff
and what I have being very honest
you are heard just because of the
controversy between the brothers and the
sisters fighting back and forth this
hurts even more than whatever wrong that
may happen and you know why Eddie is so
important to consult with his cause
before these videos you know why because
if this was wrong and this was Haram and
so very doubtful that everybody else
does it the one who originated the video
gets us in an authentic hadith the one
who first promoted basically
idol worship in Saudi Arabia so really
this this time buy back in the bird idol
Arab in Mecca specifically it was called
hoobin nobody was the idol well small
eyes of Allah I know same time says the
man who brought that Idol will be
tortured so badly for everybody that
worship the idol in Mecca but he only
did this one but this is the
consequences and on the opposite whoever
promotes something that is good and
anybody else that follows that they will
also get the reward even while the Ender
green just to quit do a quick recap I'm
not at that scholarly level to say Haram
halal but first of all I can definitely
sing that us cursing each other and
accusing our intentions as wrong I can
definitely say that when you give fatwa
signing on a las behalf that's dead
serious it can be bigger of a sin than
whatever happened and obviously number
one go to the scholars go to the amounts
that would know the surroundings and ask
them because definitely we see that this
video created some issues and definitely
some people view as positive and I just
want to show you some of the confusion
that perhaps have happened and we don't
use this as means to block it completely
when a non-muslim comes and he says I
can't even shake hands with a Muslim
woman I know you shake your whole body
in front of me how doubtful that think
that man becomes was just it gets a
little difficult as you know I'm
focusing mostly of the dancing because
music
so I respect those who listen to use of
instruments or respect that even myself
magic myself I actually tried to avoid
musical instruments and maybe Eddie I
watched your video you might have some
knowledge about that maybe can share
some afterwards but the point being is
that consult and you'll be safe in sha
allah and when you consult be evening
even if you're wrong
alone unless you fourth some people
would say look that you know now muslims
you we have our identity muslims are
those who submit to the will of the
creator we have a blueprint the crown in
the sunnah and just in itself when you
live islam when you follow the
guidelines that allah has set forth
that's the darwin and so being unique
but now if you're compromising in a way
just to fit in to blend in you're
getting desensitized are you actually
doing good for the dow are you doing
good for yourself see this is one of the
dangerous things have you ready is that
many times when the pressure comes on us
we tend to go outside the scope which
allah allowed us to be within but we go
outside just to please other people and
that's what comes really dangerous if
you feel so pressured that that's why
there's a lot of sincerity behind it
allah knows best
some people may do things outside that
circle just for Allah but the action
itself is incorrect remember this was so
a life of Allah as I've said whoever
seeks to please the people under the
cost of displeasing Allah Allah will be
displeased by that person and that's
enough of a punishment but Allah will
also make those people whom you tried to
please to be displeased by you
and lastly whoever tries to please Allah
under the cost of displeasing people
there's no other way a lot of the pleas
by you and that's enough of a reward but
I'll also add that these people to be
pleased by you that's beautiful well and
with that for this side we'll be right
back with more but when you work to
please the Creator even at the expense
this pleasing the people Allah will be
pleased with that's the main thing you
know I'll also be generous and also meet
the people and then eventually they're
gonna be pleased with you too because
the hearts are in control by the Creator
we're gonna be right back with more to
cover this happy topic how's that
beautiful cuz we got our happy side
right here brother who tryin to be happy
the being show we'll be right back with
more happy soon that's what makes me
happy and that's the truth because some
happy cuz I have to know about good on
and that's where I get my rules because
I'm happy and I have the Sun now which
dictates up and I should do and I'm so
happy
alhamdulillah we don't try to change a
Deen I'm so happy my dua to Allah
please protect our Deen I mean and I'm
not happy when they tried to change it
slump because this thing is the truth
don't try to change it in fact you can
never change it because it sounds a
truth I think nowadays music is probably
one of the easiest means to lose your
moral sense it is music is audio
pornography today that's what it is it's
explicit it's shameless it's vulgar it
takes your sense of humanity away from
you it makes you look at women as
objects worse than objects worse than
animals just as and then these people
are talking about women like they're
talking about you know an animal really
it objectifies women and especially I've
noticed a lot of the brothers that I
know are Muslims that are really into
the hip-hop scene and they're kind of
doing the hip of the song right there
memorizing the song and they're really
good at reciting of the perfect did you
eat too right and so they they do that
and it's just a horrible language
horrible horrific horrific language you
know the only simple response I have to
that if you have any regard for the Book
of Allah that you really think it's from
Allah say this willful supermodel iman
even the name then mention the word of
something the word for something bad is
terrible once you have faith even the
mention of something terrible is
horrible for you it's harmful for you
after you have faith you have to have a
clean tongue you have to say what you
only
by the unity accent tell my slave to say
that which is the best say what is the
best say good things from your mouth
back here on the Dean show we're talking
about happiness trying to be wanna be
everyone is seeking to be happy to
contempt and that's the true richness in
life now tell us you know I had assigned
for me don't you have a sign absolutely
where's your cell is it halfway uh-huh
so it's black and white yeah because
happiness but Eddie and contentment can
come while you even crying that's true
that's right so yes a Muslim can be
happy and content while they're upset
bother sad or other in pain so whenever
we view happiness is something in the
heart and only in the control of Allah
span Owatonna who in the world can have
a son at the age of 62 years old roughly
around the age after he lost Abdullah Al
Qasimi muscle acid and after all these
years he had a son with them the brahim
he loved him so much and Allah willed
with his wisdom and Hakeem do all wise
he planned that Abraham would die in the
presence of Muhammad Rasul Allah and
Muhammad SAW said Allah he cried and all
sahaba was so amazed that you Muhammad
had the heart of contentment and
happiness and you're crying he told us a
harbour yes in the liner the I teddy my
cries were in the held by the heart he
has and gets sad were in daily fear
after kaaya Abraham they were so sad of
the depart a ssin of Ibraheem however
when an a-hole we will not say except my
you do not Bona wherever pleases Allah
span that as we won't say so yes we will
be content and contentment comes in the
heart and only through a lot spine
without employing these Commandments you
can see actually some of the most
miserable people who when you wash their
videos you know some of these
celebrities and people who are doing the
most dancing the most you know
provocative things out there shaking its
shaking the rump and whatnot and you'll
find most of them most of them are the
most unhappiest people but can't you be
a person who's not doing something like
what they're doing imitating them and
you could be happiest absolutely
actually Eddie what is that's - quote
what is really happiness what is really
happiness you know what no one better
answered his questions then the one who
manufactured me and you make sense yes
so he made us Allah Spano Attalla
and he sent us that menu which is the
Quran and in it it tells you how to be
happy as simple as that so a lot of
hantai says in the Quran I would've been
left of our Dean Cevallos refuge from
the devil bismillah r-rahman r-rahim
name of allah Spinoza Allah the most
merciful
Manami now slowly had me in Viki now and
whoever does righteous deed the car mail
or unfair female war who among men while
there are believers while happening
Allah
fellow know he and now hey I don't play
but we will give them a blessed good
life this is the formula what are they
Eman animals Allah a man believed in
Allah span over to Allah and put that
into action this is the requirement have
faith in your heart and put it into
action tell you what if someone doesn't
have these two requirements and they say
they're happy
what are they dancing the clubs the
celebrities are so are they happy that's
a lot of us unless it's in another verse
which is they receive you said in please
just and we we love the contents in the
Quran we love that confidence right so
Allah says Danakil key taboo
Lari buffet which means this is the book
there's no doubt in it we love the
conference and Muslims we get we
basically increase or amount through
these beautiful verses so Allah says
women are all that I'm victory whoever
deviates away from the remembrance of
Allah from the path of Allah Fenella
whom I you shittin banker they don't
have a miserable life
I'm not calling this to make fun of
people or mark them we seek Allah's
refuge but we'll give him reality so
Allah says if you move away from the
right path of doing things right okay
Quran and Sunnah then you have a
miserable life with your wife with your
family children work colleagues sports
etc so whatever celebrities they claim
to be happy and all these profile
pictures and so on they're actually
unhappy even if they come hoping for my
shirt
tell me Majid stop talking we're happy I
say what Allah you're not happy because
Allah who made you and me said whoever
deviates away from the path of Allah
they're unhappy basically tell us does
money fame celebrity status you know
dancing all day is this what brings
happiness okay so let me pick the most
famous
path which people say if I have this
I'll definitely happy and that path is
the most famous money right yes
so can money bring happiness you know
sometimes people that are just like a
bit worried like okay no money never
brings happiness but those would say
that if I give you a ten thousand dollar
check as a gift or during three a smile
to you won't you probably have this big
nice sign and and nice and hold it right
you'll be
be happy now there's many big happiness
the answer is absolutely yes
rather money is one of the greatest
means to ever attain the happiest
moments in this life and the afterlife
as long and Eddy as long as you have
what you have your man a man without a
many anything that you do you'll never
be going to find this for the people
that don't know what the man means for a
lot of the naive Muslims tuning in so a
man to believe in allah subhanho wa
taala first and foremost the Creator
that happens in the greater the heavens
in the earth means lost parent data to
believe in the messengers Prophet Esaias
salaam Jesus was a prophet Muhammad was
a prophet he wasn't mean being just like
us just like us however they're perfect
they're infallible they don't do
mistakes no one neuron is alcoholic or a
dictate to this it's enough to believe
in Allah and decree your every decreed
upon us and we believe as Muslims a man
goes up and goes down goes up and goes
down on and off so the more righteous
deeds that you do the more amend that
you have which means that the more many
have they means that what the more a man
that means the happier you'll be happier
the more content the lesser amend that
you have the lesser contentment the
lesser the happy less happy then you're
not holding the happy side no more happy
maybe you're holding a mess or you're
holding it and you're faking the phone
it's possible this possibly impossible
absolutely so Anna man obviously there's
a lot of things basically a man is what
has been installed in the heart or
instilled in the heart whatever is said
through your tongue and that whatever is
basically put into action sound so a man
no one can see EEMA is just in the heart
a period no a man must be translated
into actually you gotta walk the talk
right so when you do off the talk and so
on thats the means of you gaining
happiness contentment in this life and
the afterlife money money definitely can
be the means of happiness as long as
part of a man you get it from a resource
you spend it in a halal way and you
enjoy your life will at 10:00 CET Nosema
can in dunya Allah says in the Quran and
don't forget your share in the donee I'm
gonna buy a Corvette go for it
I'm gonna buy a mansion golfer but as
long as you're fulfilling your duties
right from one lines of Allah you ascend
and he says the in the middle dunya bad
enough for and this dunya there are four
kinds of people number one a man or a
woman who Allah blessed with wealth and
knowledge
Eman and meant lamella what happens for
Hawaii ducky laughing so he fears along
with that money
wait and he connects
the ties of kinship the Prophet says for
whom will be of those Manasseh this
person is at the highest levels ever
then the other person which many people
are watching us right now they have what
have the knowledge but have no money
what what about them Rasool why so I
said it says for who else are upon me O
Lord but they have a truthful intention
so because it was all intention the
Prophet says they say had I have money
like that rich guy I would have donated
or have done this and that the Prophet
says for a Jew who - Allah they will
also be at the same level so it does
bring you happiness remember who was the
richest person ever walked on earth you
had this gentleman jack know the which
is e time of the man who made the lot of
winning yes but okay you know what who
was the richest person ever walked on
earth who's the richest richest richest
go ahead tell me today man I used to
know yes yes the Prophet yes he made a
lot of notes and here the man he said oh
Allah forgive me and he called al I
didn't call her grave he didn't call
someone else even beg someone he mail
himself you went to almost found out
there's there's a man yes I said all I
give me a kingdom that no one ever had
no one ever has and no one will ever
ever have and I'm like gifted to say man
wasn't he happy with that money yes
Muhammad's Allah said have so much money
between two mountains after the Battle
of her name and a Muslim came to him he
was so amazed about the wolf the Prophet
was a millionaire at that point and he
was so amazed by this and the problem
has said it's all yours it's all mine
success all yours because money was in
their hands whatever their hearts that's
right my new is always in their hands
over their hearts and when money goes
from the hand it's okay but it goes from
the heart it breaks it I want you to
when we come back give us some live
examples all City from Corcoran current
time current time examples happy want to
be happy you're gonna learn much more
when we come back God willing here in
the D show don't go anywhere
but you figure out that you know man has
to have a purpose if you were to take
away mosquitoes from the planet within a
few months everything dies if you just
took away what the mosquito when the
scale is a fact
right that's a fact mosquitoes
mosquitoes but if you take away mankind
nothing happens so this whole ecosystem
this whole wheel in this whole cycle
does it need you so why are you here
welcome back to the D show and we're
gonna give you some current examples of
people who might have won the lotto big
money big banks so the question was does
money fame you know because celebrity
status is bring true happiness
we gave example of the last a
fundamental part Muhammad peace be upon
him
prophet Sulayman they were the happiest
they had now the other side
so we said money brings you happiness
yes if it's with accompanied with a man
absolutely
now what if you take the a man component
well why they live nothing but in misery
because Allah said women are not an
addictive NLO merit n1k they were
miserable by because they moved away for
the path of Allah Eddy examples are none
ending it's everywhere what he want to
start Jack Jack Whittaker yes jack so
Jack Whittaker at one point he had the
largest lottery ticket there was a money
ever on earth at one point those few
years back so he took all that money he
came in all these television all those
shows and he was expressing how rich he
was and so on now let now cuz we're in
the future now we know exactly what
happened and anyone can watch a
documentary I should go read yourself to
show you how an immense taken out
happiness is not there first of all Jack
Whitaker in quick summary he ended up
going to bars and nightclubs all night
long he comes back home drunk and his
wife complains about them so number one
in the family not happy by the way how
much was the money about one hundred and
fourteen million dollars roughly
speaking hundred fourteen million back
Jack wasn't a thirteenth 314 million 340
million was a lot a ticket however he
chose to take it on the spot okay guy so
he think on the spot you know the
government sees a lot of taxes and so on
so 114 is not too bad right oh so you
got all that money and then how did he
behave clubs drunk how can you have me
hang on you're drunk strip clubs and so
on and the relationship in the house was
going down so now right away
did money bring happy to the family no
absolutely not his granddaughter went to
drums have some his own relatives were
murdered and killed
it's an extent that has wife she says
and he can call her almost word for word
she said I wish when I got the lottery
ticket from Jack that I would rip her
apart before he went and cast it in
imagine - Tareq said she was willing to
live in that normal life but not go to
that extent and you know what Jack to
what extent of somehow misery he went
first Jed Whitaker Jack Whitaker yeah he
went to the parking lots and he can
check out this yourself and he would
talk to a married couple or a
boyfriend/girlfriend and he would talk
to the guy how much would it cost to
sleep with your wife or your girlfriend
to that extent of degrading
that's how money took him to thinking is
better than anyone in the world and now
you can see the end results not really
happy you go to christina onassis
christina onassis she's the daughter of
one of the richest people ever walked on
earth and during our current time his
name is aristotle onassis who had the
shipping Empire a multi
multi-millionaire even billionaire at
one point three and a half years old as
for her father bought a yacht for 3.5
million dollars or 6.5 million roughly
that they're underage Christina said
daddy was this she said that's your
playground that's how rich they were at
one point her brother died and at one
point her father died so at that time
Christina became the richest girl ever
walked on earth and that's a recent
again there's a documentary about on
YouTube so Kristi knows all that money
was she really happy you go after one
marriage she got divorced from a guy and
a lane and she was willing to sacrifice
all that money because of that marriage
because her father told her if you
gettin up game a to that guy I will no
longer give you money and she went and
gets her father she got married Tim bye
father actually still give her the money
they got divorced after some time she
got married to a guy from Greece got
divorced after some time she got made
the guy from Russia a guy asked how can
communism coincide with capitalism and
then Christina says I'm looking for
what's the word happy in happiness she
couldn't find it
then it went beyond and she got divorced
were married for the last time so a guy
from France and now she's got a child
from and her daughter plays in the
Olympics by the way she's a horseback
rider now with all this being said
definite she's happy with that man after
the child but children didn't give her
happiness marriage they give her
happiness money does not give her
happiness and Allah told us woman I'll
gladly clean
monka have a miserable knife cuz a lot
told us she was found at the age of 37
years old Eddie in Argentina and bonus
iris in a luxurious Country Club in the
bathroom in the bathtub dead due to drug
overdose if she's happy she would not
even be willing to sleep if she's happy
she'll try to maximize the amount of
money she can spend and everything
possible to be happy but why did she
choose to leave this world you know what
she said word for word word for word
Eddie what's her she said if happy if
money brings happiness no she said I'll
see the reward us again she said money
does not bring you happiness and the
biggest proof is our family so she
reached the pinnacle she tells everybody
that strung up that ladder for money she
said it's not here I'm the top of the
top there's no one richer wharf a female
that has more money than me it's not
here it does not bring you happiness
you wanna go to fame can fame bringing
happiness fame absolutely brings you
happiness as long as you don't seek it
Allah says in sort of Baha what a fan I
like that
Vikrant go translation we made you
famous Muhammad SAW 7 being mentioned
every second every split of a second but
wasn't he had with that fame absolutely
making drought for the Prophet but
you're on lost money on selling etc but
that Fame benefited him because he had a
man without a man you'd be miserable
he'd look for example at Justin Bieber
but whether what's your proof Allah says
men some mass in Malibu meaning whoever
seeks to be praised on a tongues of
people and be famous Allah will make
them famous but in complete opposite of
what they sought Justin Bieber seeking
Fame we know from a lot of parents Allah
that eventually things bad would happen
and already happened all the drugs that
he's been taking all the weed that he's
been smoking you look at Elvis Presley
this is the son of Allah Allah Smith the
dodge in the world you move away from a
lie you seek all these things alone will
show your true colors I was it a large
refuge from showing Ultra Gosei I mean
and ask a lot to make my words and your
last words and everybody's last words
not so Allah Elvis Presley he was he was
accused by the video but right as the
one who promoted pornography in the US
by the way the Elvis Presley after some
time Allah exposed him now he's being
called Elvis the pelvis I need to hate
that nickname
how was he dead there's a lot of
controversy he was found not on old age
in his bathroom
which man all the girls around
definitely he's happy girls money fame
like what else he was found in his
bathroom half naked well he wasn't
Italian forgive my language and he was
throwing up and he was found dead while
his face was in the place where he threw
up for taking drugs
Allah Akbar but with all this being said
the question that comes afterwards how
can we maximize happiness I'll mention
one thing one actually item the biggest
way to ever maximize happiness and make
it to the next level pay attention habit
is relative from one person another
person not all of us are I was happy the
more good deeds that you do the proper
ones the happier that you will be and
the fastest way to do so is we need to
do good to other people that's the
fastest and easiest way to Inc maximize
that circle of happiness masha'Allah
we're almost out of time so maximizing
happiness being good to people doing
good to others living this Deen living
it not just by talking by action getting
to know it living it and what advice do
you have there's some things that are
clear that if you have the right
intention because everything's based on
your intention you're not doing it for
show for show-off
you do things for the pleasure of your
Creator and now you are guaranteed these
rewards and inshallah God willing
paradise Jenna now there's some things
that are doubtful so what advice do you
have some people who might have some you
know good intention you ask a lot to
reward the people for their good
intention but now it has to be based on
knowledge knowledge precedes action can
we can you give some advice to people
who want to do good for the Dean right
so how can they continue the zeal and
make sure that at the end they're gonna
get rewarded for that and not being some
trouble on a date guys talk to us how
sad would it be that you would do all
that work that would record this show at
the end of the day unless that's why he
did was wrong it was so sad right as I'm
traveling right all the way here and it
almost says it's wrong it may said we
ask a lot to to grant us the new or the
light and the guidance to whatever it
pleases him I must parent Anna but Eddie
Allah says very clearly famine can yell
Judith Colorado every would like to seek
a loss pounds pleasure and guru agenda
and have all the goodness there are two
conditions for any act of Porsche to be
accepted not to associate the intention
with anyone else and to make sure that
action to be correct it has been a
calling to Quran and Sunnah so if I feel
so motivated
I'm afraid Lahore fire got my attention
since here well except five Ricard alone
except because therefore you might be
doing a lot of
they're so sincere and we believe you
but the work if it's not if it's
incorrect a lot matter might not accept
it so definitely definitely knowledge is
key you have to seek know you have to
humble yourself you know I mean you have
to take some time go ask your scholars
those with with good knowledge sound not
that you trust understands your culture
understand society and they might give
you some alternatives for better data
give you alternatives the best way ever
to approach the message and you yourself
might know it but when you have that
foundation sometimes the foundation is
very important to move forward and
gaining happiness in this life and the
afterlife and remember it's in the heart
contentment you might cry but I still
have the contentment and that can only
happen when you have the a man they
believe in Allah subhanAllah may Allah
help us to be able to truly be happy and
to have the best in this light the best
in the hereafter by pleasing him working
to live this way of life so we can meet
our Creator within please wait for us
and we can get the gen9 and ask what
ultimate happiness is is it beautiful
thank you so much thank you very much I
mean you - thank you so much discipline
and thank you for tuning in to the D so
happy that was the theme of this week's
show and hopefully God willing you've
gotten some great advice that you can
benefit from today right now and you can
be happy and the best way to be happy is
how by obeying your Creator by doing the
things that he's told us to do and
almost some woman o Muslim woman who has
been honored with Islam the crater's
called you a Muslim is one who submits
not to a man or a woman to stick a stone
a bone no one but to create or he's
honored you so continue to honor
yourself and don't let no one with all
the temptation and all the things that
are trying to pull you away from your
Deen you stay strong and you hold on to
your Deen and go ahead and shake it for
your husband girl don't shake it for no
one in the world other than the one that
you can be shaking it for that you know
you'll get the reward for God loves you
a lot
loves you and don't compromise your Deen
ever because at the end you'll die and
then what you have if you work to please
the people at the expense of displeasing
Allah may Allah help us the Creator help
us to please our Creator before we meet
our Creator so we can be successful in
this life and get done on the next
follow us like us on our social media
pages and we hope
to see you again here with us every week
until next time peace be with you